thoughts that should not be
controversial I don't like Marvel movies
oh it is controversial Oh No how do I
preface this video without getting any
hate if you like Marvel movies don't
worry that's your opinion and I just
have my I made a video a few days ago
saying why I don't like Marvel movies
and I sort of memed it pretty hard and
people got really angry and I didn't
realize people were so passionately
defensive about Marvel movies for some
reason and since so many people had so
many different thoughts around it I
thought why don't I just go a little
deeper with my point on why I don't like
them or at least why I don't like them
anymore my first argument was over
saturation I don't know how anyone can
really defend this point but I'll go
through it anyway we have iron man you
had the Hulk
I remain again Thor Captain America
Avengers Iron Man again Thor again
Captain America again guardians of the
galaxy Avengers again ant-man Civil War
Doctor Strange guardians of the galaxy
again thank God spider-man Thor again
and black panther oh you thought that
was it no no no no no let's not forget
about x-men Logan Wolverine x-men x-men
spider-man spider-man spider-man
spider-man Deadpool daredevil Fantastic
Four and Podesta cool I'm definitely
wrong for being tired of Marvel movies I
just don't understand how how I can I
know it's completely unreasonable to
think that way there's just no way at
all to come up with this conclusion I
must just be crazy or something now
don't get me wrong I really like
superhero movies growing up spider-man
for example I thought was so cool to see
a superhero movie that I recognized on
the big screen for the very first time
it wasn't something I was familiar with
before and I just thought that concept
was really really cool but then once you
watch one two three four five six you
sort of get that they're all the same
movie packaged differently they all
follow the same story and concept at the
end of the day sure Deadpool is a very
different superhero than spider-man but
at the end of the day all these films
can be summarized as superhero has
superpowers super villain has
superpowers super hero ones peace super
villain ones destruction they fight and
super hero wins hooray
please direct me to any one of these
thirty movies that doesn't follow this
form right you know at the end of the
movie where the villain is fighting the
superhero and there's this this moment
of suspense where you feel like oh [ __ ]
I really want the superhero to win but
then you know oh the movies about to
wrap up any minute now because he's
about to fight back and the superhero
will win and there will be a happy shot
where everyone is just happy in the end
at the end it just removes any form of
joy of suspense because you they are so
painfully predictable if at least one of
these movies went on a different path at
least I would think okay maybe this one
will be different but it's all the same
every single time and digging deeper
into the meat and the bone other films I
won't get too much into every single
aspect but one thing that I personally
don't enjoy by this Marvel movie is that
they realize so heavily on special
effects
[Music]
it just feels too unreal it just feels
too unrealistic it's like I'm watching
an animated film with nothing really
artistically interesting or impressive
about it as opposed to Dark Knight for
example where where you watch this scene
and you're like whoa they actually did
flip a giant truck in the middle of New
York City that's really cool there's
something interesting and admire about
that you have the John wick films which
I'm not gonna show cuz it'll get
demonetized but you see the talent of
Keanu Reeves the actor you see his
movement and you see what he does he
doesn't need a thousand animators
working on every single detail of the
shot trying to make the person look cool
it's the it's the actor himself being
cool shits on marble watch his enemy
feeling special is Marvel and superhero
movies and praises animate shut up Felix
movies based on comic books are better
than your stupid anime shows don't watch
superhero films because they're not real
says the anime Fame they're for kids
since the guy who decorates his room
with anime guard there's just so much
wrong with this I don't even know where
to begin first of all I don't like anime
I know I know I know come to him I love
anime I don't like Shonen anime Shonen
anime is what's targeted for teens
between 12 and 18 and that's the same
thing really with Marvel movies they're
there for teenagers but for some reason
it's still allowed for grown men to
enjoy and cry about these films being
interesting it's like watching adults
cry about Naruto sure I loved Naruto and
I loved one piece and I loved bleach
when I was a teenager but then after
going through all of them you sort of
realized same thing with Marvel films
they're all the same thing packaged
differently you know what you're going
to get you know what you can expect out
of these forms of media so after a while
it just doesn't become appealing anymore
because you've already experienced it
you already know what you're gonna get
out of it but even then okay if you're
gonna bring up the whole concept of
anime at least you haven't leaked
hundreds of thousands of people coming
up with hundreds of ideas and literally
only the best ones will truly stick and
you have some really interesting and
unique concepts of characters and all
these things instead of just one guy
coming up with different area duration
zuv basically the same concept people
worship Stanley like he's some sort of
godlike creature and which gives me to
my my next point which is the cult
surrounding the Marvel movies it's
freaky it's me
it's a guy dressed in a suit you're
screaming at a guy dressed in a suit a
lot of people said this argument to me
as well that they just grew up with
comic books and that's why they gets so
excited about it but I don't really get
that either to be honest I practically
grew up playing World of Warcraft I
couldn't care less about the Warcraft
movie I loved watching Star Wars movies
as a kid but now I'm just not interested
in them anymore I just don't understand
this point where we got into my next
point which I brought up in my original
video which is we need to stop
fetishizing the idea of idolizing
superheroes I genuinely think it's
damaging and I said this because they're
not real and everyone just completely
jumped on me saying so what's my point
wasn't that it wasn't real my point is
that it's super they have superpowers
right it's not achievable to have
superpowers
you're idolizing something that's
impossible you're idolizing a personal
trait that just has been giving to them
most of the times for free if you want
to bring up anime again then at least
Naruto worked hard to get history powers
to become who he is he didn't just get
superpowers by bidding on a goddamn
spider okay let's drop the whole anime
point my point is that what's what's so
admirable about idolizing a superhero
what is the positive message the fact
that they want to do something good is
that what's so so great about them that
they're striving to make the world a
better place
Oh whooping 'i do who does a what about
a superhero movie that tackles the idea
what really is good and what really is
evil oh wait they already did that and
he sure as hell wasn't Marvel you either
die a hero or you'll live long enough to
see yourself become a villain there are
a good superhero movies still I'm not
I'm not denying that but Marvel just are
so shallow they all just rely on looking
cool and having quirky and dumb jokes
everywhere and never giving you
something actually of substance
that's why I get so bored watching them
and and and don't get me wrong I'm not
even a DC fanboy like I've given up on
that as well Congrats to the entire
black panther team because of you young
people will finally see superheroes that
look like them
way to put more emphasis on race than
what is necessary at all that's right I
can't idolize anime figures because I'm
not Japanese this is impossible
oh that's right I can't idolize
Lightning McQueen from cars 1 and 2
because he's a vehicle of Transportation
and I'm just a mere mortal human being
why not teach kids that their own morals
and values comes from themselves and not
from their skin instead of oh you look
like this person so you can be like this
because you have the same complexion of
skin and even if this idea was so great
why did it take 18 films for black
panther to come out is it because social
politics is more popular than ever and
it's actually very monetizable or it's
because they actually want to do
something good and positive hmm I wonder
which one and if it's so admirable why
hasn't there been a female superhero
movie yet why I know that's coming out
but it's like after what 20 of them why
hasn't there been as Mexican superhero
yet hmm why not an Eskimo hello
I am an Eskimo Who am I supposed to
idolize Here I am so lost last but not
least an infinity war apparently a big
deal of the movies that a lot of
superheroes die but I'm not gonna
spoiler which ones or anything like that
but let's just entertain the idea that
let's say I remind dies in an infinitive
war do you actually and people are
treating this like this is a really big
deal but do you actually think they're
gonna just then stop making Iron Man
movies do you think that franchise is
just somehow completely gone they're
gonna be prequels are gonna be different
you're reiterations different actors
they're still making spider-man movies
that's sort of the point as long as they
keep making money it's not gonna stop
and to me personally there's something
very unappealing about that it sort of
lacks any form of artistic integrity
sure a lot of animates
suffer from this as well they just don't
know when to stop as long as they keep
making money then they're gonna keep
going but there's so many other great
movies that are completely overshadowed
by all these comic book movies that are
all to me the same thing if you're on a
teenager I couldn't care less if you
like these movies like knock yourself
out
I enjoy them as a teenager as well but
seeing the cult of frantic screaming
adults crying about these movies still
it's insane to me I think there's
something wrong about our culture and
this is not stopping anytime soon
there's so many movies still coming out
as you can see here they already
announced half of them who actually
cares about the next ant-man like it
blows my mind I don't get it you you
literally have a new superhero movie out
before the next one even comes out on
the DVD how many superhero movies do you
need at the end of the day I don't care
you you're free to like whatever you
want I like it doesn't bother me if I
meet someone that say they like it I
just personally don't agree with it and
here's the reason why I don't like
Marvel movies thank you for watching
this video leave a like if you agree
with me leave two likes if you disagree
with me check out represent calm sigh
PewDiePie it's a great way to support
the channel and we've sold over ten
thousand of the merch so far I am
extremely grateful thank you to everyone
who supported it it really it's
incredible I'm very very proud and very
very thankful so thank you be free and
be happy do whatever you want I at the
end of the day I don't care this is just
a rant video